more than half a million people in
Florida are still without power more
than a week after Hurricane Emma but all
of the Florida Keys are now open to
residents and business owners for the
first time since that island chain was
evacuated ahead of the storm nine deaths
related to Erma have been reported in
the keys Manuel Bojorquez is in Isla
morado one of the many villages where
the recovery has barely begun Manuel
good morning good morning the hurricane
struck here with such force it ripped
this roof clean off of this gas station
it's unclear when the pumps will be back
up and running and that's the reason
officials are warning anyone coming back
to the keys that essential services like
fuel electricity sewer even clean
running water those are all limited
right now so authorities are asking
residents to be as self-sufficient as
possible more than a week after
Hurricane Irma slammed into the Florida
Keys the devastated island chain is far
from how people like Diane and Bart
Finch left it so this is not your boat
no I have no idea who it belongs to
however we do have that fell numbers on
it County officials are urging those
returning to bring water food tents and
small air conditioners to help escape
the 90 degree heat but I want to also
tell you at the same time when you
evacuated you're not coming back to the
same Keys that you left police and
National Guard troops are operating
nearly two dozen checkpoints to enforce
security throughout the islands the wall
pretty much fell off evacuees like Jared
and Erin Robertson are among those who
were finally allowed to return to their
homes on Sunday half of it looks like he
came afore they had only been able to
check on the condition of their house
using satellite images of the
devastation what was it like just to
drive in okay war zone obviously the
trees and the stuff like that we're down
in the leaves we're going but I noticed
the sand on the islands is what I missed
that the lack of sand on the islands
despite losing most of what they owned
they say they plan on rebuilding as soon
as possible it'll be okay we'll get
through it
so you can do recovery centers are being
set up in the keys to help homeowners
like the Robertsons apply for FEMA
relief and get insurance claims started
and overnight curfew is in effect to try
to protect some of these neighborhoods
Charlie Manuel thanks so much